That means if I were faster I would
probably also like to do the 200 m
race, but unfortunately I'm not fast
enough for the 100 and 200, that's why
I actually started with 800
and then concentrated on the 400
and it's really
possible  I say it's a love-hate relationship
because, as I said, you have to
go beyond your limits every day and it
often happens that I actually
throw up after training because
you just suffer
somewhere
or millions
yes so how should I say I have e.g. I
can say it as an example I
got an offer two months ago last month from a
well-known brand but I just
say hey I'm not 100%
behind it I feel  I'm not comfortable with that,
I can't do it, I don't want to do it
and that
would have been in the mid to high six-figure
range. Welcome to the
OMR podcast episode, which I'm really
looking forward to because it has to do with the Olympics,
which is next year and there
is also  I'm already
looking forward to it. I'll definitely
be there in Paris as a spectator. You
'll notice that it's about sport, that's
my sweet spot and it's an
exciting story that suits us very well
because it's a mixture of
sports
influencer testimonial model  Also
welcome Alissa Schmidt hi
Alissa hello, I'm very pleased that I can
be here today, I'm a
busy listener so yes, it's
really a small honor for me
that I can now sit here in front of the
microphone, so thank you very much, um,
I  I think a lot of people
can relate to you when you say
athlete
and model, you've
really reached a lot of people in the last few years,
so you've had an amazing career.
How many people are
currently following you
on Instagram? There are 4.7 million on
TikTok, I think  Millions and on
YouTube a little over 100,000 I mean
okay and they're not all
Germans but mostly Germans,
exactly I also have an international
audience but the majority are from
Germany but when you post
you mostly post in English no it
happens like that  I do
n't have a straight line that I
drive sometimes it's in English
sometimes it's in German I speak in German
when I talk in the stories
and I also do
English subtitles every now and then depending on where I'm
saying  This might also be of
interest to others, but as I said,
I do it a bit based on feeling,
but to explain where you
actually come from, you told
me that in the preliminary interview. You
clearly started out as an athlete and you're
from Worms. I think that's exactly who I am  I was
born in Worms and then very
quickly, I think I was half a
year later, I moved to Ingerstadt
with my family and then
went to school there and exactly after I
graduated from
school I moved to just pursue
my sport
to follow up again and how was it? You were also
particularly
fast in the 400 m run at the national youth game and then
the teachers said, well,
man, Alisa, how about some
athletic training in the afternoon
or something like that? I've actually
always been very good  And I've
always loved competition, so I
've always loved sprinting, I've
always enjoyed competing against others, especially against the boys. I've always wanted
to be faster than the boys and I have
to say I've
tried everything, so I danced  I
did judo and leichlek too
and then it became
clear relatively quickly that okay, in
leichletik, especially in the running area,
I simply have a relatively great
strength and yes, that
crystallized over the years and
then I settled on it  specialized and why there are
GBE yes 100 to choose from there are 200
to choose from there are 400 there GBE 800
yes why that why 400 m I
honestly ask myself that often
because the 400 m is already somewhere
like that and it can be such a death distance  You could
almost say that you simply push
yourself to and
beyond your limits incredibly often, which means that if I
were faster I would probably
also like to do the 200 m race, but
unfortunately I'm not fast enough for the 100
and 200, which is exactly why I'm with you
I actually started 800 and then
concentrated on the 400 and it's
really, you could say,
a love-hate relationship because, as I said, you have to
go beyond your limits every day and it
often happens that I actually
throw up after training
Just like that, you're suffering somewhere, but
it's also just the best feeling
afterwards when you've done it and you're
pushing yourself and you notice
this progress somewhere, you notice you're making progress
and I do that personally,
for example, we're in a super, super great
training group  We're a super team,
it's an individual sport,
but we still support each other so
much that we go through it together and
become stronger together, in my opinion. In the
end, we're talking about the length that you
torture yourself with, 50 seconds, yes 50
seconds EFR, but I can do it  I would advise everyone
when you're on a sports field,
on an athletics field,
try to run a lap as fast as you can
and please tell me
how you feel afterwards, so you tackle
it all out, so it's all
400 m is a full throttle sprint
You don't really think about sprinting, it's a
bit like the art of finding the perfect pace,
but I would say 90%
or 100% of it doesn't work, then
you're out after 200 m or 250 m and
nothing works anymore, but that's exactly it
This
very fast, relaxed running is a
bit of an art. I have
already done it with Matz Hummels or
Kailaume, for example. They both
said afterwards that it was a hell of a
distance. We have to
talk about it, so before that happened, Matz
and Kai  and so the whole crazy thing,
you were just there in Ingolstadt and
ran and then always
faster than your competitor and
then at some point you were at the national
level at the German
Championships and how did it
come about that you now
had a breakthrough, so to speak  I think
I had the real breakthrough, or what does
breakthrough mean, when I was 16, I
definitely started taking it seriously
and saying okay, that's really what
I want to do, I want to
go to international championships, I
want to see where my limit is
I can achieve that and then I really wanted to do the whole thing
professionally
and I think I was
in the national team for the first time when I
was 16-17, although no,
that was even later, I think I was
then 18-19, I would say um and um
Exactly, I did my Abitur
and then
moved to a new place. Sportlk er no, not that,
but unfortunately I didn't go to a
sports school. I think I would always advise my children to do that
because
I think they're just great with
sports  It was
n't that easy for me to agree on at the time either, um
but of course something like that is of course important.
I'm also doing my studies on the
side now, um because you just
need another source of support. That's
also important, especially now in athletics.
You can't just rely on it
because it is  just maybe I can
do it if I'm lucky
if I'm up to 30 32 and then but it's
not a job that you're actually interested in now as
such, you're
different because you now also
have advertising contracts because of your
reach but usually as
Now in your area what
you earn
is of course very
different, but I can definitely
say it's not easy to make a
living from it, so I can get you the Sporthilfe if you
're in the national team,
that's about €700 a
month and  Otherwise you are
exactly, you get
entry bonuses or entry fees
or competition bonuses every now and then in competitions if you
win something, but for me personally it's
not so much that I
could live off it now, that's
your trainers then my
trainers are exactly my trainers
employed by the club or the association,
which means I don't actually have to
pay it unless I look for
someone externally, but if someone travels somewhere,
I mean if now then my
coach comes with me
For example, I
paid for the flights for my trainer so that he could
come with me and but in my opinion it was
difficult for me to pay 700 € a month, so
you just have to see for yourself
how you position yourself. There are, for example,
the Bundeswehr or the
Federal Police where you can go  By the way,
it can be combined quite well with sport,
but only the very
best come in. So I'll say the
top 2 per discipline come in, which means it
's definitely not a solution for the amount of athletes
and otherwise
through sponsors
Look for yourself, yes, and then it becomes difficult, which is why
almost
every athlete does something on the side, either
studying at the federal level with the
police
because something else was already there for you,
so in addition to the
modeling activities, you
have something else  After graduating from high school
I did a voluntary social year,
but I think it
was 600 euros, which means it
was also difficult, but good, then
I had 1200 euros a month through Sporthilfe and
the FSJ
and then that
Luckily for me,
I started
looking for sponsors relatively quickly or they
approached me and I was able to
agree on that quite well. What was
the social media breakthrough, so to speak?
That was in 2017 when I had my first
international championship
I won silver with the 4 x 400 m relay
and the Beier
European Championships, sorry, and it
was a very
defining moment for me because it was such an incentive.
I definitely want to achieve that again
and I want to see what happens  what what
is possible and yes then it
kind of started like that I was
in the media for a bit and it got
a bit hyped up and
I
had 100,000 followers on Instagram relatively quickly
and that then changed with that  It's
just increased over the years, which is to say, but
at this one tournament a particularly
large number came or not because of the
tournament alone but through the
media afterwards and through the articles that
followed it, then
just over time, I don't know,
maybe it was  a total of two
months later that I
lost 100,000 okay but that
somehow means you didn't do anything different
than your colleagues or mine
or I did in 2017, Instagram was
n't as big an issue
as it is today but  I've
always liked to post, so I've
always liked to take people with me
and show them what I do
and from that I
probably gave a little more
insight than my
teammates and that's how it
developed. In my opinion it's already
100,000  Now somehow a few
million is a
journey again, but it's been a few
years now, so it's
definitely a process, but there wasn't
a big bang, it's all grown in a very,
very linear way, exactly, it
's everything  Of course there are things
like Tokyo 2021, the Olympic
Games, which of course I
think I got a million
followers or I
also had a shoot with BVB
back then, that's exactly what helped me too,
for example the YouTube video  with Matz
Hummels, how did that come about? One and
one approached me at the time and
wanted to do a shoot with one of
the sponsors of Borussia Dortmund, exactly,
and they created a YouTube format
where they simply, I think,
coached with four fitness coaches,
so to speak  We wanted to create workouts
together with the footballers that
could be done by every man and that's how
the contact came about and then I
asked Matz, don't you even want to run a
400 m race against me? I think it's
actually a cool duel because we're
really often compared  We
sprinters, the footballers are
faster anyway and I wanted to see if
that was really true and of course you have to
say 400 m is a distance that they do
n't train for,
they aren't trained
to run 400 m fast,
who has it  won in the end,
luckily I actually won.
Yes, I would say it was a
clear
lead, but good, of course, it
might look
completely different again, but it was definitely
a cool challenge and had a
lot of fun  I think but would
you also play against the others at
Dortmund there are a few like
Ademi or something like that who are really fast, yes
WD I'm really
interested but would you
also like to see the really fast footballers
so let's take it now  not mbappé
or something like that they are significantly faster
than Zumels if you would beat them too
I don't know that so I ca
n't say of course it really depends
on the distance so I do
n't think I have a chance at 100 m and I'm
not the fastest either  on 100
m but 400 m in any case,
I'm sure that I
would actually beat almost any footballer
because they're just not used to this
training intensity, they
're what you train,
you train 400
m or you train often  very often totally totally
varied so we do a
lot of strength at the moment we actually do
strength training five to six times a week then we do a lot of
jumps a lot of endurance then
of course a lot of sprinting of course
a lot of lacta training you say lactate
what no so lactate is this  but in the
blood this component exactly so the
muscles just shut down completely and
that's exactly what you need for the 400 m
and I don't think a
soccer player necessarily needs that that's why
yes I'm intense so high
intensity exactly yes so for example a
training program  I have
no idea now 3 x 300 m all-out with a
15 minute break in between,
everyone is welcome to try it out and
tell me how they
feel afterwards, as I said, so I lie
on the ground for half an hour
and can't do anything anymore because I
I'm just a complete knockout, okay, it's
not that bad in general
when you're doing sports, so to speak, where at the
end the competition is somehow a minute
long. I mean, I've
already asked myself that at 100 m. At 4, it's a
little better, but actually you're
going to the Olympics  and you train your
whole life and then it's all over in 50
seconds. What I always
think is crazy is that in the end I train so
much and so hard so that in the end, if things
go well, I can improve by 1 tbsp 14 tbsp,
maybe six toes, maybe even
a second  but that's that
's nothing and yet there's
just so much work behind it to
achieve this, to achieve this progress you have to do so much, it's
not enough to just
train hard, train hard,
everyone does it, it's just
everything  around that how well do
I eat how well do I sleep how
well do I regenerate can I
give 100% on the track again the next day where
is where is the world record in
yours at 400 m um it's for
women  47 something from back then even
set up according to the Germans aha
um
West Germans exactly
that is utopian for me we your
best record is 50
5207 I ran this year that
my best performance is 5 seconds
slower than the world record unbelievable so
that's a number like I said the race
partly the men in Germany, it
's unimaginable how fast it is
and I can't even process it in my
head how you as a
woman can do something like that, but you have to
say that of course the
times were different back then, but nonetheless it is the same
now  from doping from doping
exactly not, there were also different
training times, others were
supported differently, but of course a
lot of things were rejected
because people were doped.
Fortunately, we now have very,
very good controls, which means, for example, I
have this appointment  I also stated that I
am in Hamburg today, which means that when
doping control
comes, the studio knows where I am and
knows where I sleep all year round
and where I travel so that I can be
found at any time. Okay,
okay and the best in the world at the
moment. Who is that?  I think Sydney Mclaulin is
the fastest in years with 48
American woman yes 48 48 seconds that's
also utopian utopian so as I said it
's unimaginable I still remember
the first time I saw her in Tokyo
she's a similar age to me so she's
also relatively young  Who are you
now? I'm 24 now, I'm going to be 25 now and, um, yes, it's
amazing to me what this young
woman has achieved,
but they're also talents of the century,
so something like that, um but what do you mean, we're talking about the
Olympics, if you can do that, you know
you'll win  You ca
n't, as an
athlete you don't actually want to say it like that. YES, but of course it
's a world away and you have to
admit it somewhere. Yes,
you often hear that now,
as in the German sports world,
that somehow people
don't train hard enough here in Germany
and that somehow
in other countries there
would be a different mentality, it has
something to do with it, not at all, no, um, for example, I
was overtrained last year, so I
trained myself to the basement, I did
too much, I
maybe wanted too much and my  My body
couldn't cope anymore, I
threw up every training session because I
was simply overstimulated and as I said,
everyone trains hard, you have to
find the art of
timing it perfectly somewhere and there are so many
factors that come into play, your
environment  It's also incredibly important, of
course, because of the talent,
especially in the sprint area, there are
people who train half the time
and are still always faster
because they simply have fast-twitch
muscle fibers, which is why
we don't train hard enough in Germany.
That's definitely not
true  I think you have to work on other
construction sites, support and
systems, that you bring people together.
We train
very differently in Germany. Everyone trains differently.
Maybe they don't exchange ideas enough. I also have to
say the trainers. I think
it's ultimately  It doesn't matter whether you're
training an Olympic champion or
someone who becomes a district champion, it wo
n't change much for the coaches
financially, okay, but let's go
back to your path, so you've
made this development in terms of sport, so to speak, we've just described it
International level is done
but in Germany you are one of the
top 2 top 3 in Germany exactly yes I
was also
in the final with the mix relay this year at the world
championship we became sieve which is definitely something
for us  It
was a very, very big step forward,
we have fought a lot in the last few years
and we have often
failed in the preliminary round and
next year the big goal is that
we will definitely make it to the final in the
mix running relay okay then exactly
mix relay is two men two  Women,
it's still relatively new but it's
really cool because you just
run together with men and it's a
mixed competition that's also
super exciting
and I ran the 4 x 4 m 4 x 400 m
women's relay m but
if you or 400  m as an individual without a
relay, I
actually didn't make it this year. Last year
I
managed to do it at the European Championships and the World Cup.
There are two women in Germany who
are faster than you and none of them
ran the norm  So no one is an individual
runner over 400 m, we all only
competed in the relay.
For me, of course, the
big goal is to go to the Olympic Games next year
in the 400 m, so not just in the
relay as much as I have to  you can still
improve on your current time, the
norm is 50 seconds 5080 so
a little over a second that's
already that's a lot so in the next few
months you have to be a second faster than
the record time to be able to get to Paris
in theory, fortunately there are still
The variant that you collect points
through competitions means that if
you are, I think, top 36 in the world,
you can
start exactly and that is the big goal for
which I now train four hours a day
and hopefully
hours five times a week VI  Hours
otherwise two hours and once a
week I have a day off so on Mondays my
day off is okay okay and these four
hours then B as described
sometimes strength training super precise
technique training strength training sprint
sprint training endurance training and
often everything combined in one unit
so you now live as  Professional in the
sense that you also have advertising partners
and and and sponsors orders since
social media has grown so much, so to speak,
when did it start with how many
thousands of followers came D so the
first big partners got
in touch wow, I think that, as I said, in
2017  Then it started that I also
had the first sponsors, um, and
then who
were the first ones?
equipment contract
and that was also the first big,
the first big achievement,
I was also super proud of the fact that I
was now a puma athlete and
I think that was, as I said, the
first contract and
I'm now under contract with Boss
We're already close friends,
you have to say, yes, I've already heard the podcast
with Daniel, it was definitely
very, very cool, yes, no, it's crazy
what the man has set up in the last two
years, how
he made the company a simple one  has
advanced has positioned again differently
how intensive are you
with BOS, so to speak, like what so how many
days or how much per month or are
you already investing a lot so
I'm I can't
count the days somehow but there are exactly
I'll say now  in Milan at the
Bost fashion show where I was in
Milan, I was actually
kindly invited and I
wanted to have never been in my life from
Mens then I was there you weren't
or at least I was there
I walked  I ran exactly the
madness W I ran everything I
met through Boss the famous
runner Alex Kilde saw who
won exactly h race kidp and such a
super ske runner then I there were a
lot of athletes this year which
I think is so cool  Boss is
n't just looking for something, it's just that there was
already an audience for Becker, there was
a Juta Leerdam e.g. I don't know if that means anything to you, a Dutch
speed skater who is also a two-time
world champion. Anthony Joshua
has also
skated for Boss several times  Matteo has already
run the show, I think this year
he was only in the audience where Matteo
Matteo baratini the tennis player stim stimt
stim and as I said, I
can't list all the names anymore
but I think there were at least Z
athletes among them  70 models
so a very, very large variation of
different people from different that's
really cool so in the end they
have it almost like a
sports brand such a squad of athletes now
that S are not just
looking for exactly this typical model but
really themselves  totally wide in
places that's why I think the show is
really extraordinary, so this
year it was crazy what they
put on the stage, I sometimes have to
apologize, I did
n't check you out. You
look very different with that, man
As a model, you transform extremely well,
so you have a completely different
look. My mom almost didn't
recognize me, but that's somehow so
cool that you can really feel like you're
a different person. It was definitely
a great evening there  yes
very very cool but I'm glad you
liked it that you were there
I didn't know yes yes well I was for me it
was pretty B I came from the airport
then to this trade fair hall where that was there
there was a huge rush in front of everyone
wanted to go in there, what's going
on here and then to get through first then
two hours late and I did
n't know anyone except Boris Becker,
that was my life for me, you come to
an event in Maand and the only one I
know is Boris Becker, then things got
better afterwards  and I met
a few media marketing
people from the industry there from Germany, but it
was, well, it's a completely different
Babbe, so it's always
really exciting for me to see because the
sports world is just a completely different one  than
this fashion and fashion industry and
that's why it's just cool for me to be
able to immerse myself and
have a completely new experience but
then I'm happy that I
can go back to my sports world
but now you have Puma and Boss or no  I
'm no longer with Puma, I'm
only
under contract with Boss, but
I don't have any other partnerships anymore.
For example, I've done a lot with eerin this year
or with lcom and I'm
already making a good selection, so
I'll say from 100 E-  Emails that
come in or 100 offers, then I
accept one or two, maybe three and
then see what suits me, what suits
my own brand, why are
you so
selective about making money for a few years,
maybe and then I want to measure it?
Ultimately, I'm hurting myself  only
when I work with a brand
that I'm not 100% committed to and
in the best case scenario it's that I've been using the
product myself for
years anyway and then
of course it's all the cooler if a
partnership arises from it
plus of course it also has to be
timely  I
just don't have a lot of time, I'm
not on
social media full-time, but my
job is to perform well on the train
and from that point of view, I
just have to see what suits me
Aren't you actually
more of an influencer than an athlete these days, so
it doesn't work that way? I ca
n't say I'll do
sports on the side and then go
to the Olympic Games next, it would be nice, but there's
so much more to it than
I said  My everyday life is four to F
hours a day of training and
then ideally physiotherapy then
I have to make sure that I
eat healthily and sleep enough, so at least 9
hours if I have an intensive
training day otherwise I ca
n't give 100% again the next day
It means it's just fully timed
you can't somehow but
in the end sport is great content for such an insta
life, that's exactly what
I like to agree with.
I love taking people with me
and showing them, hey, how life is
Actually, as a competitive athlete,
what's my daily
bread and butter, what do I do all day and
show people a little bit
what I'm
doing, but I
missed that a bit back then,
it didn't exist yet  When I was young,
I was able to follow someone
and see them closely and
get insights from them, and I'm happy
that we now have such an
opportunity
to advance the sport, especially
athletics. I think it's getting
more and more attention, but for example
TV times just German
championships are partly
broadcast and otherwise just the World Cup but I
also have to say I think light is
also a sport that
sometimes, well, still does
n't seem optimal in the media presentation, so I
always have that  The extreme example
for me is like the pole high jump is
actually a crazy thing but
if you're in a stadium then there's
a running track somewhere in the inner circle but
that's what I think is
so cool because so much is happening
at the same time so you have  not just
a competition that you can watch,
you have the 100 m sprint, you have the
high jump, you have the pole high jump,
then maybe there is also ball and of course
depending on where you
are placed, you have to look beforehand,
okay, where do I want to sit, which
discipline  I'm most interested
in that, of course I want it better, I
saw it recently, there was a star
high jump in the city center here
somehow, we do that more often now, that's
true, that's close to it, that's what it's all about. That's what
actually does it for me  It makes more sense to stage a sport like that
than if
someone were to jump in the stadium and
then you thought, okay,
crazy, but you can't
really appreciate it and you're
too far away to check it out
As an example, it's interesting to
hear that, yes, I have it, so for me
it's exactly what makes it so attractive because
we just have so many different things
that happen and it's not
somehow just over after 100 m, you
can go home  But what
happens next is another highlight,
so when I'm at a
World Cup I really enjoy it
when I have the chance
to go to the stadium and
watch a day of competition because there's just
so much happening and I'm so sick with a
fever, um and  Ultimately,
everything is broadcast on large screens in the stadium
itself, which means you
can
still watch the high jump even if you're sitting at the other end.
The portfolio approach is good because there are a
lot of different things to choose from and there's
always something for the
individual athlete  You get the feeling that they're
going a little short, I mean
at the Olympics then how many races if
you have to qualify with the
relay, for example how many races would you
have
if things go well then the preliminary
and final races so a total of four but
of course it happens so quickly  over and that's the
preliminary heat and then the final
of the relay but then that's
a mix relay and 4 times vi women's relay there
are two relays so four that means
in total you're about 4
minutes yes you can say that so that's
why it  It's crazy and
of course you absorb everything as much as
you can, but of course it's
a very short time. K
high jumps are of course much longer
there, a competition lasts an hour,
maybe two
hours, but it's this atmosphere that's
still unique  It was unbelievable
this year at the World Championships in
Budapest and the stadium was actually
sold out every evening and I had
goosebumps when I walked in there, that's
the feeling we
athletes just don't have often because it's
not often the case that a stadium
is sold out, that means it's
such a small goal for me, maybe I have
no idea in four years it's also
completely sold out at a German championship and but
you should actually do that if
someone can do it then someone with
millions of yes that's the verse
calls come to the stadium
exactly when there are German championships
that you also animate people and
show them okay vi people this is a cool
event comes by and how many people
come D so how much what do you think
how much can you pull off that can
I don't say that, I have no idea, but there are
quite a few of them, so I'm going to say that it's
the German association that's
behind it or something like that, so
that they realize that they now
have someone who
has a range lever, I think so  They
also come to me and
then ask if I
can perhaps promote something again at competitions,
especially the German Championships, and
as I said, that's really nice
to see because after the competition it's
really like there are crowds of people there
waiting for you when you
come out of the stadium and
want a photo or autograph and
but is the winner
not as
big as you or um no not quite as
big no but that's it  Not so
much that they think what's the
big deal, but the winner is
of course still asked for autographs,
so that's still the case.
People aren't interested in
me there because I
'm an influencer now, but because they
like to see me as an athlete  and that means
they are also asked for an autograph,
but it's still a bit
like that internally, well, I mean, you'll
notice that night or resentment because D, so
to speak, a person like you
now stands out, say the next
strongest or the next biggest  in the sense
of reach athlete with you how
big is the lady's account
I don't know at all I think magina
lückencamper is also quite big pa
100000 followers I can but well
we're already talking about millions of
differences yes yes of course so there are
definitely there too  Somewhere there is
resentment and people who maybe do
n't think what I'm doing is so great.
Personally, I have to say that in my
environment, luckily I don't notice
anything, so I have a lot. The
association is also everyone is happy that you're
pushing, so to speak, and the people  Of course,
that's an advantage, so you want to
make the sport more popular and that's
how big it is now, especially through social media. How big is the one
you were just talking about, the
American woman, the
world's best, with a million followers? She's also
massively smaller than yours  Massively
a million followers, that's
great, that's true, that's true, that's
not bad, as
I said, it's just a lot of
work and you should
n't underestimate that
I somehow feel like it, but
of course it's something where you
have to put in the work. The
American woman sometimes does it a lot less
than I do, for example, because she just then how
much effort is it for you,
now you post several times every day, I
have to  say I don't have a
special strategy that I'm
following in any way or that I'm
putting myself under pressure,
but I try to
post regularly because that's of course important for the
algorithm,
but now when I have a day where
I say hey completely  Honestly, today I do
n't feel like it at all. I just want to
concentrate on training today. I also don't want anyone to
post anything about the training online. Then I won't do it
either. So I'll do it a bit based
on feeling, but the platform for you is
Instagram tiktok  Instagram tiktok and
YouTube okay, exactly, so YouTube is
actually almost a bit
for myself because I just
think it's really cool when I
look at my videos from Tokyo, for example,
and review them
and
experience all the emotions again
That's the coolest thing that's possible and if
I can show it to my children at some point
that would be you have a
videographer with you or people at
such big events who also
film you, mostly films myself,
sometimes I have someone with me but for example
now the Olympics  No one was
allowed to play, that was also during the
Corona period, so no one was allowed into the
Olympic village anyway, which means I
vlogged myself. Of course, that's
not easy because you're
also concentrating on competition and you
somehow don't have
the head for it  I still have to talk to the camera all the time
and that's why
sometimes I don't do it this year, for
example at the World Cup I did
n't film because I said hey,
I really want to concentrate completely on that, I do
n't have the head for it right now, that's why I always do it like that
a bit like I feel in the end there are
only three big partners is
just called somehow boss
called lum still called so boss is
basically my my biggest long term
partner
and yes ultimately I see
what fits
there would be the possibility of it GBE  Of
course, I could
probably advertise somehow every day,
but who wants to see that? That
's the last thing you
want to do and I would
shoot myself in the foot with it and it
doesn't suit my brand if I did
something competition that doesn't suit me,
you can tell that and that's what's
coming, a yoghurt or
something else, so
car brand or something like that or telef farif
you can still
do that, yes a car brand if it's
definitely of course if it's a
car  I like that and where I say it's
cool audiw e.g. but there
are so many things where I
personally just don't stand 100% behind it
and then I don't see that you're
giving up then at the end we're
talking about money you're giving up  what
you could maybe take somehow
100,000 or millions yes
so how should I say I have e.g. I
can say it as an example I
got an offer from a well-
known brand last month last two months ago but I just
say hey I'm standing there  I'm not 100% behind it, I do
n't feel comfortable with it, I
can't do it, I don't want to do it and that
would have been in the mid to high
six-figure range, wow for
a flight or for a
few mails or for a longer
partnership that would actually just be
a campaign  So for a shorter
thing, actually just that, but you
really have to make a complete
distinction again, it's not like
I get I do
n't know how many hundreds of thousands for one post,
so I don't want to
give the wrong impression, it really depends on
where  It's advertised, it's just a posting
on my account. I'm somehow
quite big in the Hamburg airport.
I don't know what's happening in
Hamburg
so many factors, that's why you
can't really say now
that's what it's always somehow
what's always on the table, it's
completely different but yes, of
course, I often forego or often say
no to things that I simply don't
support
doesn't help me in the long term and is there something
I ask more often now because
I find it interesting and then I'm
happy if something
works out with the guests but also
especially with the people listening,
there's something else you want,
so where  s man, I also
asked David, I think she said
somehow Rolex wouldn't be bad,
although completely wrong it would have to
be a toilet but well or I GLB my
favorite story I think they
told about some houses then it
was finished afterwards
house partnership found out what is it  With
you there were two things that I
think are cool, firstly, as I said, my
goal is to make athletics more popular,
that is, if you can
somehow do a documentary with Netflix
about lightweight athletics in
Germany, I think it's absolutely awesome
I think I would only like Netflix W okay
or oh no of course not e.g. I
just mentioned Netflix there
are of course many platforms but
and there are no requests no
not for Germany at the moment I think
Netflix is ​​planning to release something about the
best sprinters worldwide next year
I think they've
already started turning things around this year,
that's natural, so I'm excited to see
what it does for the sport. I
think it's going to
have enormous potential, as we also saw
at the Tour of France drive to survive,
so that's the way it is  Things you
just get people excited about the
sport, okay, so I
totally understand that, that's exactly what I do, that's exactly what
I think is very, very cool and otherwise
we also travel very often, that means with
an airline, which of course is
n't bad either, you have to
imagine for example  I found that unbelievable we
traveled to Tok how long do you think
the journey took to the
Olympic Games as athletes we
have to perform there we have to
be physically fit how long do you think
the journey
took you probably
changed trains somewhere in Dubai  or
or something like
that and then you're on the road for 20
hours or so, that was well over 30
hours. I think we had a stay of
12 hours in Tok itself and then we
had to change airports again
to a small island where we
had our preparatory training camp.
You fly economy  Class, of course,
always
I think it was there at the time,
I think that partly because the
economy was fully booked, partly because
I would say 40% of the athletes were allowed to
fly business, that was random, that
means a few were lucky and
were then really allowed to  Flying business,
that was a dream, the rest were allowed to go to the
other side in the 1920s,
the athletes went by ship,
yes of course, but you have to
think about it, that's old Pat,
our body is our capital if
I'm somehow 30 40  Hours
I'm somewhere really small and then
I'm unbelievable at the Olympic Games,
yes, that's just one of those things,
it could definitely go better,
but how many Olympic Games do you
still have in you so now Paris in
next year and  La comes 228 in any
case, that's the big goal, yes,
but for you it's always the
relay thing, so no, not at all, so
I'll take a look, so after Paris, there
might be a little
change for me, I'm still there
a bit in planning in the look
I don't want to say so much yet but
but so Umswung could be called Bib,
the slightly loyal definitely but
maybe W I'll try something new let's
see what could that
be realistic so run 800 m or
e.g  yes or high jump or something like that
I could also imagine jumping as cool
but that's but can you
still do it so you could now
if you now go up to s you say I'm
going to go up to or long jump mean there are
careers that used to exist
Drexler 100 m and long jump Exactly 100
and long jump can be combined very, very well.
As I said, I think I'm
up for a new challenge
again and to see again,
hey, how can I possibly prove myself in
a different field?
develop further how much can I still
get out of it so I'm already talking about
jumping and then no more about no
no no I'm actually in the mood for other
runs what obstacle actually also cool too
cool I think they say a
little bit the older you get the longer it gets
the route you can say like that
maybe you'll see me
at the marathon at some point I don't believe it I do
n't believe it no but you never know
and that's why but is that really
realistic so I mean now say that
you're going on an endurance dance now
no that could be  But that's
realistic, I think I could
also very well also from
MS, of course it would still be a
years-long process, so I
can't say I'm training
endurance here now and I'll be
at the Olympic Games next year
over 10 or none over a half marathon
marathon that for God's sake there
's no way it's a years-long
process but as I said I
'm definitely keen
to try something different and let's
see what it's going to be or if it's going to be
that at all but  Exactly the goal
is to make it easy to learn up to 228, in any case, to be
healthy and B ne
here something in terms of studies, exactly I'm
studying media and
communication management as a distance learning course and I'm doing it in a
stretched manner, so I'm
not studying in the standard period of study,
otherwise I just wouldn't be able to fit everything
together and  Of course, but the
focus is study, that means you really do
everything exactly in the online online and
then I'm, for example, now I'm going
to the training camp four more times before the Olympic Games,
three of them just for
several weeks to South Africa, which
means you just have to
be flexible too  and can simply work from many places and
study and that's
why it was perfect for me, what is
the name of all the
400 followers or all the corpses from
Germany or who is there
in the training camps the
national team so the
throwers too  and and jumpers
and so right now normally
we almost always only have the same
discipline, now at the beginning
we have a kickoff training camp
that starts in Z D weeks and
the whole national team is there, which
is of course great because you just have to do it
again  You can exchange ideas better and
otherwise you're just always in
your little babble with the same
people and it's cool to get to know all the
other discipline groups better
and just connect with whoever
was faster, be Matz
hummelz or K flaume Matz hummelz
faster but Kai is also crazy,
I think Kai is mentally ill. We're
talking now on November 2nd,
I think today, and I spoke to him on the
phone a few days ago and
he told me that he was running the New York
Marathon
I've been preparing for half a year and
I'm really excited to see how he's
going to do because he really
prepared for it like a complete professional, so it's
unbelievable what he can do,
but of course that's of course again
you have to say 400 m  It's a
sprint distance marathon is something completely
different, but I gave all these
events a push every time.
I mean, I'm still trying
to understand how you get from the
first 100,000 to
becoming rich. I understand it
's also important  You were there early so you
did it at a time but instam
still a little smaller at least but there
weren't any
accompanying circumstances, okay partnerships
or maybe that helped you
but there must have been something there,
as I said, exactly the
Olympic Games have them  brought me
about a million followers back then
and then there are also
things like, for example, if it
goes really viral now, for example, I've now
posted a real one that I think has
around 80 million views, so of
course I also benefited enormously from that
and
I still benefit from it, so I still do it
like
that, it's just me looking at
the camera, so basically
at the beginning of a competition the camera always comes
and introduces us athletes and
then of course, in the best case scenario, you laugh even though
I have to say it's really
difficult, I have no idea, to laugh
so nicely into the camera the minute before the competition
because you just I'm in such
a beast mode, you could say
I'm so in in in in in focus, that
is  I laugh briefly into the camera
and then I'm straight back to
myself and let this laughter disappear
and that's when I had the
idea. I just came up with a sound like that.
I can't describe the sound right now,
exactly where it is  then it
goes from happy to bad and yes that
was no idea second video and it just
went viral then you can
also predict that a little bit beforehand
so I can actually
tell you with my knowledge that it will be well
received, it will be very good  arrive that
will arrive mediocre how long have you been
a model in the
situation I mean I mean you are an athlete
but I mean it hasn't
gone unnoticed that the
partnerships
work well because you
are a particularly attractive looking person so what is how far  That's
a topic for you, so I think that
was reinforced a bit by Boss
because I
was really involved in their campaigns
and
their productions too and that
was completely new territory for me
because you  You came to the set and there
are 100 people working for a shoot
so that the perfect picture
comes out. I didn't know anything like that
before, but you have to make sure that you put on your
make-up differently, for example, or of
course you will be made up there exactly
as you will  First it takes two hours to get
ready, then
there is one person for everything, I get
dressed there, I don't even have to
tie my own shoelaces somehow, there
is a model in front of me that the set
runs through everything completely, which
means that they look exactly where the
light is  perfect, how does it have to sit? That
means that it's not me, but that an
external model is doing it in front of me, that I only
come to set that that just
worked better in terms of time because you also have real
model orders D away from the
boss where  you somehow do
n't have time for that, it doesn't work, so
running or something like that,
no, that's that, that's also a model. Being a model
is an incredibly hard job,
unbelievable, so now that I've
noticed it a little bit,
I'm happy when I'm back  As I
said, I'm coming back to my sports world,
of course it's also hard training mm
but this modeling job is hard in a
different way so it's a
business I think it's TFF
you have to be made for it and um
to do it every day that would
n't be the case  Mine but what does that mean so
modeling in that sense you do
n't actually do it so I'm I
would never call myself a model
no but that somehow W
books you for shoots it just does
n't work I don't have
time for it I just can't  say
hey okay today I'm going to
Hamburg and I'm
on the shooting job all day something like today, for example,
fits well because I
already did my ice bath this morning I
trained this morning ice bath yes
today is my regeneration day that's why it's perfect
It's good, but a
day of shooting like this is incredibly tiring.
I can't say the next day that
I stood on set for 10 hours yesterday
and today I'm training
super hard again. That doesn't work because
you're always training
alone or always in a group  always
in the group where where are you currently training
in Berlin okay you currently live in
Berlin yes exactly I live near
Berlin and exactly fah but I
always say actually around 20 30 minutes so
yes super relaxed can be
arranged easily and then  are we a
group, we are a relatively large and
also a very, very strong
training group, I would even say
almost the strongest training group in
Germany now
at a club then at my club
exactly with what's its name SCC Berlin okay
okay they have also recruited themselves, so to speak
So when you were instad then they
said, man, come to us,
unfortunately it doesn't work that way, no, but
you say you choose for yourself
where do I want to live, where do
I have a good group, where is a good
trainer and it was for me  The option is
actually only in Berlin because there
is a very good trainer there who I am
now training with, who also has a lot of
very good 400 m runners and it
is not the case that I am now paying me monthly for it like in fß
fball
that I'm
in the club, I also get a small
amount of money, which
I probably wouldn't even be able to
cover my food for the month, but it
's still nice that they
support me, but as I said, that
's in Germany, so we will
Not really, we are not employed
by the club but we are all
independent athletes and
it is actually the case for you
now that you are here in Hamburg
or now in Berlin using the S-Bahn
or something like that or the inner city
Is that even possible or
are you now immediately in love
with a lot of people? No, it's not possible at
all, so I'll definitely be recognized and you'll
notice that even if you're
secretly filmed
or whispered to or, as I
said, someone comes up to me  But that
's not the case, I haven't even
secretly filmed it, it sounds
a bit like it's normal, yes
it definitely happens, so
I always find it nicer when people
just come up to you because I'm happy
too  It's huge when you somehow
meet someone from the community and
you see who is actually
behind it. For example, now at the
World Cup I
met a follower who
I've been in touch with for years, so
she writes to me regularly and from that point of view
it was right  It's cool
to just see the person behind it and do
you think that if you've
finished 28 Olympics and then
let the sport come to an end then your
social media is over for you
or do you do something else?
I've never thought about it
honestly  So let's see
what happens next, I will definitely
always stay loyal to sport. I could
n't imagine that I would
n't be able to do anything anymore and that
's not possible either. Of course, you have to
lose weight anyway after you've
done competitive sport,
but since I have  I also think there are a lot of
other fields of interest and, for example, the topic of
beauty, fashion, healthy nutrition, which is
very, very cool, so I think
as long as I enjoy it and as long as
people like it too, so influential
life will continue somehow,
you'll see, as I said, that's
me  I always don't want to say what will happen in 10
years or so, never that's
nutrition, why don't you have any
food partners or something like that, you should
actually be really close somehow,
so I don't know about any
drinks companies or I'm just imagining
who knows, maybe something will come  But of course you
have your own drinks too,
that has to be
tested down to the last detail, it's
such a long process, so it's not
dirty, so I do
n't have enough time at the moment. I'm
just concentrating on the
next year, the Olympic one  year I
also said I want to
do as little as possible on the side this year. I
really want to professionalize myself in every area.
I live for this
one session a day. I want to give 100%
every day and that's the only way
I can in the end  of the year I
have done everything and I can't
blame myself for anything and hopefully I'll be my
best version and can fulfill my dream
of the Olympic Games
but the dream is
just to really be there at the Olympics. No, I
was there in Tokyo  Story in Tokyo
I don't know if you know you
probably don't know I was injured
that was for me so I was
in the training camp the last unit the
last run I said to my
teammate hey how cool we did
n't have any physio with us because we were  I
couldn't afford it at the time and
then we said hey, cool, we
didn't hurt ourselves, everything
went well last run, what's wrong, I'm tearing
my ligament, my
outer ligament was lying on the ground and I knew
straight away, okay, it's over, it's over,
I think they were still there  Three months until
then you won't get fit that quickly and
for me then of course my
world
collapsed. Reserve run
exactly and then yes, fortunately I had a
very very very good team around me.
I found a very good osteopath back then.
Wallid is the name of the one with him  I
still work very closely together today and he
simply got me fit again as quickly as possible and
I'm
incredibly grateful for that, but of course it was
still a tough blow, so I
think I missed a total of 8 weeks of training
or had to train alternatively -
that's of course anything but
optimal and for God's sake you do
n't want that before the Olympic Games um
and I'm super grateful that I
still managed to take part, it
was it was super emotional I have to
say I have it. I still remember
exactly the last competition was in Berlin
last chance to qualify
to show what I'm capable of and then there was a
thunderstorm, it was raining, it was
pouring, it was cold, the competition
was postponed and I didn't
run well either, so it wasn't a good
competition after that and of course I was after that
devastated and knew
okay, it probably wasn't
enough. I told my parents, hey,
I'll be with you tomorrow, come to you. The
Olympic Games are over, I did
n't make it and
the next day, um, I get a call
from the national coach and, um, he said
He would like to take me with him as a
substitute runner and give me the chance to
get the insight and
just see it as an experience and did
he believe me and I get
emotional again when I
tell it, yes it is simply the greatest thing
you can do as an athlete  can reach and I
still remember h already Olympic tattoo no,
I usually get them when
I run, I was a substitute, I wasn't
on the track from where I was,
so I'll only do that when I
run, if I really do  I said I am I was
standing on the Ben I'll
know that shortly beforehand so sometime in
July so exactly shortly before then a
decision will be made who are they so unless I
run right at the beginning the norm but that will be
very difficult because the
form naturally improves  and it will
take a while to get to your peak, so
it will probably
only be
decided in July June July.
Of course, you can still
estimate a little beforehand how exactly I am,
but it will definitely be an
exciting year next  There's
still the European Championships next year and there's
another relay World Championships on
the baham, which means it's packed,
yes it sounds cool at first, but we wo
n't,
I don't think we'll see much of the
country, okay, so it's
actually always going that way  from the fact that you
're in the hotel and then you drive on the
track and train there and then
you prepare for the
competition and otherwise you don't
really see anything, it's not
actually an issue for you in such
an American college  Well,
I mean, there are a lot of
German athletes who still get really cool
scholarships, somehow I don't know
Stanford or Berkley or
something else or some big Texas
A&M, which is what they're all called. I
thought about doing that after school and
then decided relatively quickly  I
discarded the idea again because I
already appreciate what I
have in Germany, I love
living here, I have a very good
environment here and even there it's a
completely different way to train and
you can do a little bit of that  Almost
say mass processing, there are a
lot of athletes, a lot of talented
athletes but only the best get
through and
if you can't cope with that then
you have a problem, that's why
a lot of people were simply injured back then and did
n't come out well,
but there are also  the possibility now that
the best German decathlete
trains in the USA, for example, he is great
so he is also well supported there because
the perfect environment so that means
if we now want to keep our fingers crossed for
everyone who has heard this and wants to
follow you on your channels  Of
course it's possible and the decisive
moments are then the European Championships
then the
relay world championships come first in May, that's
the first big goal we have to do
is that like please when when may is that there at the
beginning of May definitely I think 1
Z dr 4  May something like that okay okay and as I
said we have to be top fit
we have to qualify for the Olympic
Games that means that will be
the first big
milestone then the
European Championships in Rome and then
the Olympic Games in Paris okay and
in the best case scenario I am  I'm with you everywhere and I'm
also good at it and what kind of time have you
set for yourself,
what time do you have to do when I see you? Of course
I
have to beat the 52 second mark first
I'm already on it for two years now, but it
all just has to come together and
then I definitely want to
run a low 51 time and I'm confident I can do that. I
've professionalized everything again this year
Let's see
where I can improve and
see what happens in the end. A
guy like me could
somehow manage 56 57 seconds
in the 400 m, yes, I would
say so you definitely have a lot of
work to do  Before, somehow,
now I'll say I've
done sprint training once or I live near
a sports field like that. Do
n't you just want to run a lap of
400 m and then write to me
how fast you were? That'll be of great
interest to me, so I even did that
Posted years ago so that was I
'm on Instagram now and I'm not
telling you anything but that was
when I started it and there was
a cinder track where I noticed it wasn't so
okay that makes a difference exactly
and then I just ran UMG  then
my hand stopped looking like that and
D then my
friend Moritz Fürste, the
hockey player, was kidding me
and said somehow it's more likely to run
with children in your arms, do you know what
time you ran, I can do it
Shortly after, wait a moment, so I
post
from August 13, 2019, that's
about four years ago and that's a
lap here you see the
photo, it's a very old
sports facility and the question is whether it's 4
or 350 m anyway  It's not entirely
clear, but I wrote that I
recently met a very fit
72-year-old here and he said that
at my age you should be able to do the 300 m lap in
under a minute, but a 300 m
lap would be really good in under 50
Seconds and then I tried it
and it was 57 seconds so if it
was 400 m then it would be really really really
good without training without
anything beforehand 57 seconds yes but I
think it's more like 300 then
Moritz Fürste comments here 18
hours K im  Cut m did you have the
kits on your arm exactly no so I
have to say 57 seconds that's not
that bad I think that's about what Matz
ran too but over 400 over 400 that
he would have outrun me by 100 m so
we've talked enough about it now
I don't know at all how to make athletics more popular. Do you have any ideas about
how you can easily use it? You think it
's quite good. You have the portfolio approach, which is the most important German event in Germany, German championships and ISFF, for example, it's
very well attended  There were
actually more spectators in Berlin
than at the German championships,
but even though
half the stadium is still empty, how can that
be? I think there is also too
little communication, so not enough people
realize that there is an event
Maybe the
tickets are relatively expensive. Other
athletes are now following your
example. I mean,
everyone has to try a little bit now,
not everyone but many say okay, what he's
doing is what I'm doing now and I'm going to
somehow make myself a little more
influential  Lots of people yes yes on
J case but it doesn't work so well but
it definitely works
very well for many people so
a lot of people have built something up on social media
and that's just super
helpful for us. A lot of people always say oh
why  You guys,
please concentrate on the sport, but you
also have to say, firstly, we also have
a life outside, we can
also deal with other topics, it
's not just about the fact that I'm
not
allowed to develop myself in any other way, plus it helps
It's just scary
for us, it's just a great point, especially for us in the light age, to
protect
ourselves somehow and to get the sport full of us,
yes, and also to enable us to take part in the sport
in general. I
also have to see where I can make a
living  Well, it doesn't work that way otherwise
and that's exactly why
making things like this more popular. Social
media is a really big topic to
encourage something like that, but you also have to
say that if it's not broadcast
and you don't see it anywhere, it's of course also
difficult  I think it would
also be helpful if you just generally
saw more leichletik on television
when you're finished now, then
one day you'll be
a millionaire or,
um, yes, I hope that's a good thing, but
many other people won't be  I can say, um,
yes, I know, I haven't
really looked into it that much. We or I do
n't actually talk about it with my competitors or team colleagues,
but
just about the sport itself, no, that's right,
you have to
be world champion and even there  you have
to say I think for an Olympic
title you get 30,000 for the Olympics,
yes that's it but that for you
is but it's crazy that you
can still do this sport and
do your whole life and still be
economically in a completely different league
Being able to play is an
absolute dream, so that's
two things that can be reconciled and that I have
a lot of fun with.
Firstly, I love my everyday life as an
athlete, so there's nothing
better for me than going to training every day.
That's it for me  the highlight the
highlight of the day to surrender and
so well okay okay okay so um I
'm really excited to see what happens next
with the Olympics especially if
you want to see you there it's
incredibly difficult to get a ticket is
so difficult and I  I know, so of course I
definitely want my
family and friends to be there and that's what
I've seen. The tickets are
incredibly expensive, so I think some of them are
€700. I've seen them. I
hope that, as I said, I
qualify first and when I do  I
qualify that I also have my
favorites, despite being a moderator
or an expert or something like that,
maybe then you don't
know, I don't know yet, oh I think that's
also super difficult if you
do. Of course, that's a deep setback even if you don't
I can do it and I don't know if I
want to be there then I'll
decide, but I'm not even thinking about it,
so for me there's only
one way and I know it'll work out,
everything's fine, good attitude,
thank you very much for being on your day off
So to speak, you came between
ice beard and vomiting and now to the
climate, thank you very much, I was very
happy, thank you very much, ciao
ciao